we start with our camera on top of the
bank of america and you see the flags
whipping
and there are some raindrops falling in
parts of town you saw hector
here with his hood on officially we're
at 51 degrees
but hanging on to 60 in the strip upper
40 summerlin
a cold front is passing through that's
why we call it fro
paw that's meteorological shorthand for
frontal passage
and scatter showers we're not talking
about big time accumulation now later
this afternoon
could be a chance for a thunderstorm if
we get the sun heating up just a little
bit
speaking of heating up we go to nevada
and beyond still
66 in death valley part of a wind
advisory in fact there are three
different wind advisories
none of them including the las vegas
metro area over the hump and prep yours
starts at eight o'clock this morning
this one and in southern california
starts at 11. there's one for boulder
city and the colorado river all the way
down towards laughlin that starts at 3
p.m
there will not be a quiz on this because
the bottom line is
it's just going to be windy all day
today
all night tonight and most of the day
tomorrow you've got some snow showers up
in alien 24 cedar you got some snow
showers and 30.
good morning to kingman with a 48. so
hour by hour at 8 o'clock we'll try for
54 with clouds and wind maybe some storm
clouds at noon and 60
a possibility some thunder along with
the wind and 64 at three
that's the forecast high temperature and
then maybe
62 at six o'clock still very windy so
your weather headlines
all of the wind advisories do not
include las vegas widely scattered
showers and thunderstorms
our eight day forecast coming up with
temperatures reaching 80
by next week so for today we'll go for
64 where the normal high would be 72
i don't think it's going to feel like 64
with all of the cloud cover
and most definitely all of that wind
there's that junior weather buddy talk
we got
fro paw or frontal passage right through
southern nevada during the day today so
we got wind ahead of it we're going to
have very strong wind behind it as well
checking on your family and friends the
system we had over the weekend that's
turning into strong
showers and thunderstorms from the
dakotas all the way down to mississippi
here's your eight day forecast we'll go
back to 68 with the wind continuing
70 and breezy on thursday a dip back to
the upper 60s and then we start climbing
back up
we are looking at a possibility of 80 by
mond